thank you very much it gives me great
pleasure to introduce our next speaker
to the Bicentennial symposium dr.
Charles Sawyer's is the chair of the
inaugural chair of the human oncology
and pathogenesis program at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center
he's a Howard Hughes investigator and
he's the Kravis chair at Memorial
sloan-kettering dr. Sawyer's was born in
Nashville attended Princeton the only
flaw in his CV to date following that
went to Johns Hopkins for medical school
UCSF for his training and then
eventually went to UCLA where he worked
with Owen Witte and became interested in
kinase --es and in targeted therapies he
as I'd mentioned now a Howard Hughes
investigator he's won the Lasker Award
and also won the karnovski award from a
scope doctor Sawyer's is the embodiment
of what it means to be a successful
translational researcher someone who has
taken the observations and findings from
his laboratory and applied it to a real
and important clinical problem when you
think about the disease chronic
myelogenous leukemia before the work of
Charles Sawyer's environment Zee's where
people lived 3-5 years if you had an
allogeneic match you might have a chance
of having a long term survival but the
vast majority of patients didn't have an
allogenic match until their work showed
that the BCR Abel and the Abel kinase
could be inhibited by the drug imatinib
and Charles's work to define these
pathways and mechanisms have had an
enormous impact on human disease great
pleasure to introduce dr. Charles
Sawyer's
well thank you Tom and thank all of you
for coming back after such a lovely
Friday afternoon it's really a great
honor to be included in this lineup um
we're all you know reading either in the
newspaper or in the journals about all
the exciting new targeted cancer
therapies and what I want to do in my
time is not debunk that excitement but
tell you the other side of the story
which is of course drug resistance this
is a common theme with any cancer drug
and it's a it's an increasingly common
thing with the targeted therapies the
good news I hope that you'll take from
my talk is that we have a much better
mechanistic understanding of how these
therapies work at least we should when
we put them into the clinic and
therefore we have some clues as to why
they might stop working and I'm going to
tell you three vignettes in three
different diseases about the approach
we're taking to address this I have one
disclosure the second story I'm going to
tell isn't going to involve a drug
called md v 3100 that's in clinical
development and i was a co-inventor and
i own stock in the company and but what
I'm telling you is gonna have all the
truth the
so here are the three examples I'm going
to start with chronic myeloid leukemia
then prostate cancer then lung cancer
which is something I'm a little
reluctant to speak about in front of Tom
because he's the expert but I'm going to
tell you a recent story that that I
think you'll find interesting
so as Tom said you know Gleevec has
really transformed the treatment of
chronic myeloid leukemia but there is
this problem of resistance as you know
the Philadelphia chromosome is the
driving lesion and chronic myeloid
leukemia and it produces this
constitutive kinase that be serial
fusion it took 40 years to get to this
first targeted therapy Bank but as you
know that the pace of from going from
discovery of a fusion kinase or a
mutated kinase to a small molecule
inhibitor is speeding up incredibly fast
and there are many examples that are
ongoing that you're very familiar with
in lung cancer and and melanoma very
recently the same I wanted to point out
the date of this paper April 5th 2001 at
the time that paper was published we
already had a lead on what was going on
in the patients who relapse initially
relapse was occurring in patients with
blast prices phase of CML but it also
occurs in patients in early stage
disease but not in everyone and I as I
think most of you know the the the
discovery was that the mutations that
the resistance is caused by second site
mutations in the kinase and I saw this
as an incredibly good fortune mechanism
because it told us exactly who the
culprit was and how to go at finding a
second drug but this was the crook you
know we had a press release which sort
of covered it in that angle but this is
the editorial that the Wall Street
Journal wrote what I want to tell you
now is how we use that information to
think about finding a second drug and I
think quite successful outcome that
that's led to you know all of the work
that I'm going to describe for you is
done by outstanding physician scientists
who
trained in my lab and I want to want to
acknowledge each of them as I go so this
is Neil Shaw who did the work I'm about
to show you and I'm very proud has just
been promoted to associate professor at
UCSF what Neil did together with
Mercedes Gore when we were seeing
patients acquire resistance to Gleevec
was sequence the BCR Abel kinase domain
from samples that we obtained in the
clinic we started doing that because we
had looked biochemically at the cells
first to ask the question is when
Gleevec is on board the patients are
taking the drug every day when we first
start therapy we could show that be
sharable kinase activity was inhibited
using various essays of kinase activity
in the cells and now when they're
relapsing the main question was is it
inhibited and there's some other
mechanism of resistance or is it or does
kinase activity restored kinase activity
was restored in essentially every sample
we looked at and therefore we jumped on
the possibility that something must be
different about this you're able and I
think as many of you know the first
thing we found was this mutation here
which is become a famous example of a
generalizable phenomenon called
gatekeeper mutations they're deep in the
ATP binding pocket as I'll show you on a
structural slide and they generally form
hydrogen bonds with a lot of the ATP
competitive inhibitors of many different
kinds and the list continues to grow of
examples of patients with different
diseases who develop resistance to the
appropriate kinase inhibitor due to
mutation of this site if that were just
the only problem her only mechanism of
resistance you can envision perhaps
making a second drug that could cover
that substitution and therefore coming
at the disease with a two drug cocktail
but as Neil dug deeper in the sequence
more and more patients the the problem
began to grow and its complexity and now
we know of at least 50 different amino
acid substitutions that are associated
with Gleevec resistance and we know in
every single case if you read engineer
the mutation into a model system it
confers varying degrees of resistance to
the
and in vitro assays so at this point I
was fortunate enough to link up with
John Korean structural biologists at
Berkeley who had just solved the first
crystal structure of able bound to
Gleevec and this is a picture of that
here's Gleevec is the drug and gold and
here's the able kinase domain in gray
and what I've pointed out is a couple of
interesting regions each of the colored
residues are balls is the residue where
a mutation has occurred so this is the T
3 15 hi mutation that forms a hydrogen
bond with the drug and the substitution
there create puts a bulky isoleucine and
therefore causes resistance through
steric hindrance when you start to look
at this pattern and you see mutations
way over here in the activation loop and
in the phosphate binding loop and it was
not at all clear how they could be
causing resistance so in puzzling it
over this structure with John's group
modeling in each of the different new
amino acids and looking at the predicted
effects on the structure we came up with
the following proposal I'm just going to
turn this for you and I hope you can
appreciate that this part of the
activation loop is company should
envision it coming out of the board
after you in the drug this part of the
drug running behind it so that was an
important insight when John solved this
structure because it shows that the
kinase is in the what's called the
closed conformation when when the drug
is bound and the prediction is that
because of this portion of the molecules
is that the the Gleevec shouldn't be
able to bind the open conformation and
when we did the modeling studies the
prediction was that the substitutions in
general favored an active or open
conformation of the molecule and
therefore we proposed that resistance
was caused by the inability of the
enzyme to achieve this closed shape and
therefore bind the drug a prediction
from that would be that a second
compound which was agnostic about the
shape of the act or the position of the
activation loop and combined in the open
conformation might be effective against
some of these mutants
so I actually literally prepare
that at a AACR meeting a cancer research
meeting you know now many years ago and
I got a call to a week later from
scientists at bristol-myers Squibb and
they said we think we might have a
compound that has those properties that
we'd like to send you and that compound
turned out to be the drug to satiny at
the time they had optimized this to be
an inhibitor of the t-cell kinase lck
and then in doing a specificity profile
notice that it also was a potent
inhibitor of able the reason that was an
important clue is because the shape of
Abel and Sark family kinases of which
lck is a member are very different in
the close conformation but very similar
in the open conformation so we put two
and two together we said maybe just a
Tanev is binding the open conformation
at the time of that discussion and
subsequent experiments we didn't have
this structure but this is a structure
that BMS solved and you can see that is
here's the compound binding in the ATP
binding site here's the phosphate
binding loop and here's the activation
loop and just to show you in an
animation the difference in binding
between dis active and Gleevec you can
see now the activation loop is closed
and that's the position in which Gleevec
combined so they're binding the same
site but in different conformational
requirements and therefore should
potentially have different activity
profiles so indeed Neel found that that
was the case this is a series of
different mutations in BCR Abel that
cause resistance to Gleevec in patients
he engineered their them into a model
system and then exposed those cells to
different concentrations of dasatinib
and you can see all of these colored
lines here are examples of sensitivity
to dis active but resistance to em at
neighbor Gleevec the one exception is
that gatekeeper mutant t3 15i which is
resistant to both compounds and remains
sort of the the Bugaboo of the field
there are some early stage compounds
that are showing some promise but we
don't yet have a clinical drug for this
particular mutant this data led
bristol-myers Squibb to agree to move
forward with a clinical trial which was
done led by myself and Moshe topaz when
he was at MD Anderson that trial
was tech was the drug was tested in
patients with chronic myeloid leukemia
who had failed imatinib and the response
rate was extremely promising in the
order of 50 60 % in the phase 1 trial
and we genotype the patients at study
entry for resistance mutations and the
summary of that is shown on this cartoon
where you see the map of the kinase
domain in each of the different colors
the either green or blue represents a
patient on the trial had that genotype
that study entry and responded either by
a complete or hematologic response or a
complete cytogenetic response and then
the only exception to response was the T
patients who had the T 3:15 I allele and
they uniformly were resistant so based
on a follow-up series of phase 2 studies
the drug was approved now just to keep
track of the dates in 2006 just 5 years
after the description of them the
resistance mechanism so I hope in that
story to present to you the two things
number one and a detailed understanding
of the target and the drug and the
interaction thereof can lead you quickly
to decipher mechanisms of resistance I
mean at least with kinase as you can
react very quickly with
second-generation compounds where we
stand today is that imatinib continues
to remain frontline therapy it has it
was approved exactly ten years ago and
these are the response rates that are
holding up but patients need to stay on
believe act essentially continuously
otherwise there's a significant risk of
relapse if they stop the drug dasatinib
as I said in a second compound called no
lotta nib were approved as second line
therapy last year at about this time the
results of an upfront trial comparing
imatinib to dis at node or imatinib to
lock nib were published in newly
diagnosed patients and in both studies
the second-generation compounds were
found to be superior to imatinib at one
year of follow-up superior in this
disease we're starting to you know parse
really good results between three
different calm
but this is defined as greater overall
response rate at one year a greater
cytogenetic remission rate greater
molecular remission rate and reduced
time to relapse and as I said the sort
of the the the the part that's left
unanswered is having a compound that is
clinically approved that would hit this
last mutant and one scenario like
envision in the future is a doublet of
two inhibitors one being this compound
that with either one of these other two
second-generation compounds as being a
way to completely in a sense shut off
all escape routes through at least V
cerebral mutation so the second story is
involves a completely different cancer
and that's prostate cancer but it shares
this theme of understanding a targeted
therapy in a certain level and then
trying to use that information to
decipher the causes of resistance so as
you know prostate cancer when it's not
cured by primary surgery or radiation
has been treated you know for decades
with hormone therapy the there's two
flavors of treatment that are both used
often in combination there are drugs
such as Luke Ron is the leading LHRH
agonist that lower serum testosterone
and therefore caused clinical response
by sort of removing the fuel for the
androgen receptor very effective therapy
and they're also a series of compounds
that are approved as competitive
antagonists for the androgen receptor
they bind the ligand binding domain and
displace testosterone or
dihydrotestosterone the two leading
drugs are by collude amide in a and flut
amide now both are very effective but
all three of these compounds the rule is
that patients will respond for a period
of time and then develop resistance now
interestingly the two antiandrogens are
well known to have mixed properties as
antagonists as well as agonists one of
the best demonstrations of that is a
clinical phenomenon called anti-androgen
withdrawal syndrome and I'll illustrate
this on this simple cartoon so this is
just meant to depict the typical course
of a patient
metastatic prostate cancer whose disease
burden is rising and the clinic usually
monitored by serum prostate specific
antigen level in the blood the patient
undergoes first round of hormone therapy
dramatic response 90% or higher of all
patients period of time goes by this
this varies depending on the stage of
the disease at which the hormone therapy
is started but typically it can be as
long as you know three four years or
perhaps even longer if it's if the
disease is caught very early but
inevitably PSA will rise and metastatic
disease will return and if a patient is
on flute imide or by colluding ID you're
taught in the in the medical oncology
clinic to stop the drug in such a
patient but not start something new
right away wait a little bit of time and
a certain fraction of patients roughly
twenty thirty percent will actually
respond have some clinical benefit to
discontinuing the anti-androgen so
formal proof that they could something
is happening in the tumor cells that
causes the cell to reinterpret this
agonist antagonist as an agonist but
that is a just a short-term benefit and
the disease progresses so I'm we were
very interested in trying to understand
what the mechanism of this recurrence is
and the approach we took this time was
to examine a series of xenograft models
that grow in this situation here by by
implanting tumors into intact male mice
then castrating the mice there's a
period of time in which the tumor either
growth arrests or regresses and then
regrows does this androgen independent
or hormone refractory stage as it has
often been termed so in this case Derek
Wells be an MD PhD student in my lab
when I was at UCLA took on this
challenge together with a postdoctoral
fellow named Charlie Chen so I'm not
going to show you that primary data but
just summarize the key findings and then
go to the next to what we did in
reaction to that
so what Derek found when he compared
expression profiles from those two
that conundrum that hormone-sensitive
versus the castrate-resistant phase of
these isogenic xenografts was that the
androgen receptor message and protein
was consistently over expressed in the
late stage disease so this was an
interesting correlation it's been
subsequently shown in patients although
we don't have examples of matched pair
sets from the same patient patients who
have castrate-resistant disease tend to
have higher steady-state levels of the
androgen receptor than patients at
diagnosis what Derek then billed was do
the necessary and sufficient experiments
of forcing androgen receptor over
expression in the castration sensitive
model and that was sufficient as a
single step to cause resistance and he
also knocked down the receptor by RNA
interference in castrate resistant lines
and that was able to restore sensitivity
but perhaps the most surprising finding
was that this simple maneuver of over
expressing the receptor about three to
five fold over endogenous which is what
we see in patients as well would cause a
cell that was responsive to by collude
amide meaning responded interpreted as
an antagonist to now see it as an
agonist so something is changing in the
balance of the receptor levels
co-activators and co-repressors that are
causing this change we're still working
on trying to figure out exactly what the
molecular details are but the in light
of this it became clear to me and to
Derek and Charlie that second-generation
anti antigens could protect be a
potential solution to castrate resistant
prostate cancer so we put this forward
to in discussions with several
pharmaceutical companies who were not
enamored by the idea and I think in
retrospect because the the the parlance
of thinking about this phase of the
disease was that it was androgen
independent in fact it went by the term
androgen independent prostate cancer so
despite this you know nice nature
medicine paper that wasn't enough to
convince anyone to launch a drug
development program so I had been
fortunate at UCLA to meet a very
accomplished synthetic chemist named
mike jung and he and i agreed after some
series of discussions to give this a
shot
so we had a cell based assay in which to
screen compounds that were cells in
which we'd engineered the androgen
receptor at these higher levels the
current drugs were resistant and the
idea was very simple
are there any small molecules we could
find that would now restore sensitivity
would interfere with androgen receptor
function in that context the approach
that worked was actually suggested by
Mike and was to take advantage of a lot
of old literature on small molecule
chemistry and binding to different
hormone receptors and in an old Rossella
cloth patent he found this structure
with goat which goes by this name which
caught his attention because of this
binding affinity that was published in
the patent and that caught his attention
because this is two orders of magnitude
higher affinity than by collude amide so
the simple you know of course we wonder
why is this gone nowhere well we made
the compound and it's a potent agonist
but what his postdoc Samedi ik did was
start to make derivatives of different
parts of this molecule and generate an
SAR of activity of compounds versus
activity in our assay so making you know
10 or 12 compounds at a time going over
to our lab screening them looking at the
results and having group meetings over a
series of about 18 months we came up
with this set of rules which is that
this part amount of the molecule cannot
be altered the RS would kill all
activity but as we build bulky groups
into this part of the molecule we start
to build in antagonism we don't have a
structure of this compound with the
antigen receptor yet we've struggled but
with modeling studies it looks like
what's happening is something that's
very consistent with knowledge from the
estrogen receptor field and that is that
these bulky groups interfere with the
ability of helix 12 to fold on top of
the ligand binding site when engaged
with the compound as it normally does
with agonists and the native hormone so
a compound from this series is now
called MDV 3100
and we called it Rd 162 the new name is
because it's been licensed to this
company Medivation that I mentioned in
the disclosure they license it based on
this kind of data so we took this
compound and treated mice in which weed
and injected prostate cancer cells that
were engineered to express this higher
level of the androgen receptor and those
tumors now grow and castrate my sleeve
and then we treated them with either
vehicle by kelud amide or the new
compound and I'm showing you the data
here in the form of a waterfall plot
where each one of these bars is a mouse
whose tumor is either growing if it goes
below zero or shrinking if it goes below
zero and this is would be complete
you know regression of a hundred percent
decrease from baseline so I think you
can see the message the compound is
extremely active in this model much more
active than by Quileute amide and this
was enough to convince Medivation to
take this compound and put it forth into
a Phase one clinical trial and I'll tell
you about that in a second but in the
meantime we were went back to understand
why is it working so much better is it
just because of the increase in binding
affinity are there other properties so I
just want to tell you that I think the
answer is because there are other
properties and I'll just show you to you
in this cartoon so this is the androgen
receptor which as you know when it's
unlimited is in the cytoplasm bound to
heat shock proteins such as hsp90 when
when ligand binds androgen in this case
you under the receptor undergoes a
conformational change transfer case of
the nucleus binds to DNA target sites
and assembles an active transcription
complex interestingly when by Kalu
divide binds it actually the sort of
life cycle of the receptor is not that
different
still undergoes the conformational
change translocates the nucleus binds
almost all of the same number of target
sites as we've now some shown by chip
seek but is believed to exert its
agonist and antagonistic properties by
assembling a complex that's not optimal
including the recruitment of
co-repressors such as inkelaar and smart
so we asked in our new compound and you
know what's what are those steps here
and what we find is that is designed as
I said to bind exactly the same site so
it's displacing androgen a
conformational change which we can't you
know get our hands on structurally yet
occurs but only about 20% of the pool of
the androgen receptor makes it across to
the nucleus and of that pool that gets
there we can find no evidence that any
of it can bind DNA at all most recently
by Chip seek experiments so I think this
is a fundamentally different effect on
the receptor that I suspect may explain
its activity in the meantime Howard
shear a colleague at sloan-kettering who
runs the GU Oncology Group took this
became the principal investigator of the
Phase one clinical trial of the compound
so as in any first in human study it was
a dose escalation three patients per
cohort and the test population was
castrate-resistant prostate cancer so
men who failed all hormonal therapies
some men were eligible for chemotherapy
and as you'll see both groups of men
were tested the first three patients
were treated with a dose that we
suspected would be far too low to have
any therapeutic effect but almost
miraculously all three men had a subtle
decline in the serum PSA level within
the first 28 days there were no side
effects so the next dose was tested that
was 60 milligrams and again all three
patients at that cohort had declines in
serum PSA so the company made a very
drastic change in the protocol and that
was to rapidly accrue 24 additional
patients to each dose level once they
had acquired safety on the first three
and of those twenty four twelve were
chemo naive meaning they hadn't been
treated with standard therapy which is
tax adhere and twelve who had actually
failed that as well so this phase one
study which was meant to enroll 30 to 40
patients ended up accruing 140 over
about a year and a half and the results
of that in terms of PSA response
here so again this is a waterfall plot
and it's sort of divided into two halves
depending on whether it's the group that
was chemotherapy naive versus post
chemotherapy this distinction is
important in thinking about how to
design the next clinical trial but the
aunt the exciting result is that in both
groups there's dramatic drops in serum
PSA the GU oncology community uses a
cut-off of a sustained drop of greater
than 50 percent for 12 weeks as being
something important not necessarily
proof that your drugs can improve
survival but something you know very
exciting and that's what we were seeing
in both of these cohorts roughly 50
percent complete response rate or PSA
response rate we also saw evidence of
benefit in terms of other measures such
as radiographic changes I won't go
through the details other than show you
that there was a there were shrinkage of
soft tissue disease and stabilization of
bone scans that is that are also
considered important milestones so
what's happening now is that the drug is
in a phase 3 registration trial in this
post chemotherapy population being
compared to best supportive care and is
expected to read out sometime at the end
of this year so I mean you may know
there's another drug that goes by the
name abiraterone which lowers serum
testosterone levels not hitting the
androgen receptor by by blocking
residual testosterone production by the
adrenal gland that drug was actually
approved I think yesterday by the FDA
for showing activity in exactly the same
patient population the data this kind of
data on abiraterone are very similar to
two to what I've shown you here so the
hope of course is that this drug will
also show activity and perhaps the two
together you know shutting off more
ligand production and blocking the
receptor more potently might also be an
interesting combination but what I now
want to do is point out this group of
patients which our patients who clearly
flat out do not benefit at all from the
compound and if I drew the circle a
little bigger you would see that their
patients who have this sort of ho-hum
modest drop in serum PSA level that
tends to last only for
about three to six months and then those
patients tend to progress so there's
clearly a resistance problem now with
this new drug and we're actively working
on that I don't have the answer yet but
I want to show you some very recent work
that's unpublished from some mouse
models and this is the work of Brett
Carver who's a urologist in my group who
operates two days a week and spends
three days a week or actually five days
a week a typical surgeon in the lab and
I don't know if he ever goes home but um
this is the route so the question that
we asked was one that you know we can't
take a global look at these patients
currently I mean I'd love to get
expression profiles or mutation analysis
profiles on tissue from these patients
but for reasons that aren't really worth
going into it's very difficult to access
tissue in this patient population and we
just don't have the opportunity now but
hopefully we will in the future
so in the meantime we're taking some
guesses so p10 is a guess why well it's
a common lesion sort of his frequency
would match with the with the frequency
of resistance and there's data from
others in breast cancer you know breast
cancers often have mutations in pik3ca
the pi3 kinase isoform and those
patients sometimes attention that those
mutations can sometimes mitigate the
response to hormone therapy and breast
cancer so there's precedent for the pi3
kinase signaling pathway to to perhaps
to play a role here so what Brett did
was test our drug in a conditional p10
knockout model this is a well-studied
model in the field these mice developed
early pre neoplasia and then they
develop cancer by about six months of
age and we can follow this by doing MRI
scans on the mice and you know detect
eligible subjects and then treat them on
essentially a mouse clinical protocol so
we have two different mice mouse models
that we looked at here in this
experiment so this is a mick transgenic
model that i'll just we just used sort
of as a control and then here's the p10
model and you can see the tumors in the
nick model shrink 80% or so over a five
week period of time whereas the p10 mice
have a very modest response this is
this is shrinkage and untreated mice the
tumors actually grow so it is a response
but it's not something we're impressed
with this shows that you know one
explanation might be that the drugs just
not efficiently reaching the prostate
cells in this tumor model however when
we look at the expression of three
different androgen receptor target genes
in the prostates of these minus five
days after we start treating you can see
this is this is about 50 fold reduction
in the expression of these genes of
course we can clearly hit those genes
even harder in the NIC model so maybe we
can get greater potency with higher
doses but we also can see I hope you can
tell in the androgen receptor in those
two chemistry of these tumors hopefully
you can see this bright staining here in
the nuclei this is the antigen receptor
and this panel here from drug treat
treated mice the androgen receptor is
not nearly as nuclear so showing that
the drug is having that effect that I
mentioned of impairing nuclear
translocation so this points to p10 as a
potential resistance marker it also
raises an exciting new possibility and
that is if we use an inhibitor of the
pi3 kinase pathway which is up regulated
in these mice maybe we can you know have
a better treatment response than this so
we did that using a compound called BZ
235 that's a experimental compound
that's in clinical development Novartis
is is taking it forward it is a it's a
it's not a pure pi3 kinase inhibitor it
hits mTOR and torque to complex it's an
ATP competitive inhibitor of Tor and it
also hits pi3 kinase and the doses we're
giving we can document inhibition of pi3
kinase signaling as measured with a
phosphor akt antibody and also
inhibition of tor signaling with this
downstream readout of tor activity we
can see that the proliferation of the
cells is impaired in the p10 model it's
there's really no effect in the Mik
model interestingly with a pi3 kinase
inhibitor but we don't see much tumor
shrinkage that's shown here so here's
the control group you can see the
killers do grow over this five-week
period of time but they only shrink
about 20%
with the pi3 kinase inhibitor so why is
this well we posited that perhaps the
androgen receptor is now exerting this
survival signal that the tumour you know
still has in there but we're not able to
kill the cells so we see a proliferation
effect but not a cell death effect
that's substantial so we decided to look
at the antigen receptor pathway in these
animals after treatment with this drug
and to our surprise what we found is
that inhibition of the pi3 kinase
pathway toward paradoxically activates
the androgen receptor so the evidence
for that is probably best shown here
these are this is the expression of
three androgen receptor target genes in
baseline and this is five days after
adding the pi3 kinase inhibitor you see
a big up regulation an expression of
roughly 15 to 20 fold of some of the
target genes we can model this in cell
lines using reporters and different Tor
inhibitors for apt inhibitors all share
this property of activating androgen
receptor transcriptional activity and
actually stabilizing the receptor when
we when we inhibit this pathway so this
is obviously something that we don't
want to be happening in prostate cancer
cells and it's very reminiscent of some
observations that Neal Rosen another
colleague at sloan-kettering has made
over the last couple of years so many of
you are probably familiar with this
observation that inhibition of M torque
one with rapamycin and analogs can
paradoxically activate a KT an upstream
you know part of the pathway by
relieving negative feedback that's
mediated through this signal neil has
more recently found that with an AKC
inhibitor there's a another over layer
level to this feedback transcriptional
control of certain receptor tyrosine
kinases is disabled or activated when
you add the a KT inhibitor and
paradoxically you see more her - her 3
phosphorylation in breast cancer cells
when you add in a KT inhibitor so it
turns out we are seeing exactly the same
thing we see her - her 3 activation and
prostate cancer cells when we add this
B's
we compound now how does that explain
how you can activate the androgen
receptor well several years ago my group
had actually for other reasons mapped a
pathway between her to her three and
androgen receptors so we sort of come
full circle now the inhibition of this
pathway in these p10 male prostate
cancers is activating the androgen
receptor through these her training
tsa's so of course that begs the
question of you know in addition to
loosening elucidating the molecular
details of these feedback loops just
treat with both compounds at the same
time and now you can see this is now a
hundred percent shrinkage here you can
see we're getting dramatic tumor
regressions when we use the combination
of the anti-androgen and the pi3 kinase
inhibitor even in a p10 model and in
Zeinab Roth models so the the dissection
of those feedback loops puts us towards
the following model and that is
inhibition of one pathway the pi3 kinase
pathway paradoxically leads to
activation of the other the AAR pathway
through these four kinase is and what I
won't show you for the sake of time is
that we also find the reciprocal when we
inhibit the androgen receptor pathway in
these tumors we actually activate the
Akt pathway through down regulation of a
key phosphatase that regulates a KT so
moving forward where can we go
well what I've shown you is that we
think that p10 is a resistance marker
for the MDV compound and we very much
want to ask that directly in the
patients we will get there but we have
to get more tissue in the meantime these
two pathways are very interconnected and
the prediction that is that the
compounds in this that hit this pathway
many of which are just starting to go
into prostate cancer amongst many other
cancer types I think are very unlikely
to cause clinical responses at least in
pizza and negative cancers and in fact I
think it's likely that they might cause
PSA levels to rise rather than fall
which will lead to massive confusion in
the early stages of the clinical
development of the compound and so we're
pushing very hard to get combination
therapy tested as quickly as possible
these are all clinically viable compound
and you know we are working hard to
convince the various companies who are
who are developing these drugs to work
together on this what I want to now
finish in the last couple of minutes
with is is a lung cancer story so I'm
I'm sure you've seen various versions of
this pie chart which is how the treat
had the diagnosis of lung cancer as
simply adenocarcinoma has dramatically
changed just in the last five or six
years to these different subtypes based
on their molecular phenotype or driver
mutation and as you know EGFR inhibitors
such as erlotinib have really
transformed the field now this is a
waterfall plot from data generated at
sloan-kettering by mark chris and
colleagues from from clinical trials of
several years ago and I'm showing it to
you just to make one point and that is
that what we call a response in lung
cancer is 50 is 30% shrinkage of tumor
by cat scan so everything below this
dotted line is scored as a response and
these are all EGFR mutant patients and
the point I want to make is that most of
these patients are not having complete
regressions like this most are having
partial responses and there's clearly
heterogeneity so what is the explanation
for this we hypothesized that you know
they're there other there's nothing
different in terms of the EGFR mutation
itself that can explain all of this
heterogeneity so we ask the question
perhaps their genetic modifiers other
hits that are regulating how dependent
or addicted the tumor is to the EGFR
driver mutation and because we for all
intents and purposes we we think we're
getting good blood levels in all these
patients it's very unlikely that it's a
pharmacokinetic or pharmacodynamic
difference that's explaining this so the
strategy we took to address this
question was in collaboration with Greg
Hannon at Cold Spring Harbor who as many
of you know it event has developed very
powerful RNAi screening technologies so
will you ask the question using a pooled
library can we find hairpins that would
make a lot of work better in a cell line
and this is the work of Trevor
dawna also an md/phd formerly nyu has
just completed his postdoc in my lab and
as a and works in the lung cancer clinic
at sloan-kettering so Trevor found this
cell line called H 1650 which caught my
attention because it has the right
genetic makeup it should be very
sensitive to rely on it but it's
actually and it is in the cells undergo
growth arrest but they don't die so
compared to the spectrum that EGFR
mutant lung cancer cell lines this is
relatively insensitive so we thought
that might be a good test case to now
look for enhancers of R'lyeh obtained so
we used a library that with the details
here we perfectly we used a pooled
screening approach we pulled out 36 hair
pins that were depleted in this system
when we added erlotinib and of course
looked at their names and 18 out of the
36 could be connected in some way with
NF kappa-b signaling so this was really
quite interesting because as many of you
know enough NF kappa-b is very
implicated many things but survival
signaling in cancer so the specific
hairpins we got targeted these different
components of the pathway I'm not going
to go through all of the primary data it
was recently published in Nature about a
month or so ago I'm just going to show
you data from one of them which is
critically important for the
translational implications and that is
this kinase ikk beta because because
it's you know presumably a druggable
lesion so this shows you in a xenograft
assay how these tumors grow normally
this is how you know relatively
unresponsive to relati nib they are this
shows you the effect of knocking down
ikk beta in these tumors and this shows
you now the regressions we start to see
when we add a lot in it so this is the
reason we're you know we're excited
about this pathway at least in this
model now what do we know about NF
kappa-b signaling in patients I won't
show you but we could do the reciprocal
experiment of take us take a relati nib
sensitive line and make it relatively
resistant by activating NF
be so what we know now is from this
series of samples that Rafael resolved
in Barcelona analyzed in collaboration
with our group he runs this Spanish lung
cancer oncology group and had collected
a large series of patients on clinical
trials across Spain who were all had
EGFR mutations and all were treated with
the erlotinib and biopsies were obtained
and survival data was available so he
looked at a couple of genes from our hit
list and found that the level of
expression of the inhibitor of ICAP
would be I Kappa B patients who had high
levels of I Kappa B and therefore low NF
kappa-b activity presumably had a much
better outcome in progression-free
survival as well as overall survival and
importantly this effect this prognostic
effect in this one data set didn't
transfer to a different group of EGFR
lung cancer each of our mutant lung
cancer patients who were treated with
chemotherapy that we're available data
on were available from sloan-kettering
in the days before allotment so this
sort of biomarker prediction here is
specific to this drug and not generic
for lung cancer so the implications here
are that NF kappa-b activation can
promote resistance that the expression
of this RNA level which should predict
for reduced activity of NF kappa-b is a
could be a biomarker of treatment
response and we obviously like to see
this looked at in other datasets but I
think from the translational angle the
question is can we combine an EGFR
inhibitor with an NF kappa-b
pathway inhibitor you know type of
inhibitor unknown at this point
so respond Hance response rates and
perhaps extend treatment duration so I
try to hopefully show you how with
targeted therapies we know the enemy we
know how the enemy can outsmart us if we
just look carefully and that can very
quickly lead us to solutions to acquired
resistance and I think I've mentioned
everybody along the way so I'll stop now
and the
happy to take questions thank you